my name is steve kaufmann i am the
founder of link lng community for
learning languages
i will speak in german and so i wil
tell my experience or my ta
e about language and e
pecially with relation to my exper
ence with german with german in ge
man language mean
my parents are from
czechoslovakia i was born in sweden when i was five
years old moved to canada
so my parents always spoke german
together at home but with us with
my brother and i always english
so i learned the language for myself and i
can say that i  could be more or
less good 12 was tyson
language learning languages
s on how much motivation we have
o i think that's the most
mportant the m
st important factor secon
ly how much time we spend
with the language and thirdly we ha
e to who so how do you say  so the
ability to pay attention so
attention is very very important
but di  e most important that is motivation
and when we were young
my or you the words don't
learn german because we first that's often the
way people canada we wanted to be canadian
will only speak english and we were
that was there was a resistance to
for example german
we learned french at school
but also there we could
n't speak french then when
i was 19 i wanted
to go to europe
i'm on the
port and he like then i
tried to find work on some
ship there and  i was able to find a place on a
german ship and
then i sailed across the ocean
with this german ship and
then there i first tried
to speak a little german i
had i remember i had a
book i tried all  these
changes of the of the of
learning everything it was very bad very difficult
difficult then i did a lot of
hitchhiking in europe ge  power and
sometimes in germany and from time to time
i also spoke a bit of german
but that was very very limited i
was in france for three years i
studied there afterwards so i know what
canadian diplomat next in hong
kong i studied chinese was there
afterwards
but  i in japan and since there i
warmed myself japanese and
after i have since 47 i work in the and
international wood business 87 when i left
i have worked
my this company and i would have
a month
between job and i then i decided
i have  decide i will
learn german and then i visited everyone
who got second hand and i found
a lot of books
the first year and all these books
had word treasures and that's why
i could read although there were a lot of them
you couldn't and i won't give
all show but i have a so a
large amount and i have while
inhabitant i have a lot  l solved and
also listened because i found very nice
cassettes
ordinary conversations between
ordinary people everyday conversations
and that was also very nice
although there were always a lot of words
that I couldn't know but I was
then I had the motivation I wanted to
learn that and afterwards  I also
learn languages.
I think it's very important that you
go from this part as soon as possible
to authentic texts
. These are interesting
because you can not only
learn the language but also learn a
lot about this culture  country
and so on and that's what I did too
and I have a lot of books
because I'm very interested in
history our and then here in these
books you see there are a
lot of words I don't know and that
's not just that  example with German
but also with Spanish or French
not French it works quite well
and that's why  en we have developed this link
system because it simplifies this
process
of reading and listening a
lot and accumulating the vocabulary
yes and i find language learning
in school
i know in germany it is much
more effective than in canada in canada the
mostly english speaking people  they
go to school in french for ten years
and can't speak french at all in
germany i'm always so impressed
impressed that so many people speak english very well that's
why i think the schools are
more effective
i know i was in
düsseldorf once there was a conference on
languages and  profession and i have shared some
means and then most
people who study english in their companies
or one speaks italian
or spanish
they do risk one or two hours
a week and then maybe maybe
an hour studying themselves but that is
that is not that is  nothing if i have
a language for deere and the last
ten years  re i studied russian czech
polish romanian
portuguese then i have to do something every day
and well
i do a lot so i
mainly hear because its day to do
i can do that in the car if i can do the
revenge or
something i always hear  that's why i think
that today with the internet with the
mp3 player or everything you can also find on the
internet not only
partners like for example link
but a lot of content interesting
content for example i i i wanted to
refresh my german a little bit i have
started my own company in 87
in the wood business and then in
the early 1990s we
also did a lot of business in
germany we sold but
we also bought in germany
and sold to japan
and that time i have all
spoke a lot of German but since then I have spoken
very very little German and
they will  last week because i
wanted to prepare myself for you
i found a great podcast
so there is a website poster.de and then
there are very nice podcasts on
various topics here link for
example some of our members have
very interesting podcasts in german
found and they
transcribed it all and then we had it with us
was with us in link to the library
there is always like the audio and the
texts and that is very important and
then we have a lot so functions
help us the vocabulary to akku  was empty
for me that's the important
most important thing not the grammar so i
can't do that i miss a lot
i know that but when i see these
these these tables the the demda i
can't get in
it won't get in but if i
read a lot and listen thanks gradually it
becomes a bit one gets used because
learn language that it wanted him that
its a habit I believe  h and the
passport is then say yes and because i
have learned a lot asks languages
ed to say because if you don't have any vocab
lary even
hough you have mastered it i don't think you c
n master the grammar without having a lot
of experience with the langu
ge because the  dram
explanations and tables that must have a
relationship not something that already
is one that you can already find that's
why for me the most important thing is
to hear and read a lot and
possibly to speak
and from time to time you can look at the
dramatic heroes on boys and  and
now it's like that with the internet
i can only do so german took the
people then i get this
table right away i can look at it a
bit but i won't do it it's
not possible that i'll
master everything it's not possible that that  catches
my attention a bit and
then the next time I read and
hear that maybe I'll notice
and try  try to do that
in the in or through that is
important and that's why i'm always
very interested in things that are interesting to
me and i can also,
for example i bought this audio book
belonged to the man of 50
i have the book  and i can also find the
texts that the text is on the
internet and then i can
import links and all these words i
don't know
there i can look up and listen and
read and the eeg when i was in
germany last time i have i
I bought this book for a topic in Germany and although there are a lot of words that I don't know I can more or
less understand them and all this
takes my interest
and gradually this new language
becomes a habit and so it will
you keep getting better and better and i
think if you teach them like this
language in the company two hours a
week and maybe a study
that's that's not enough that's not
enough
but i have this experience i know
how to do that because i've done the
whole thing 30 times always and i think
maybe a lot of people who are too
passive
she goes in class they have to hear
empty said  doing doing doing
for example i never do the exercises
because it is so so bad it is so
uninteresting
i prefer for example only
to see the answers not the exercises
i will never sprinkle this answer
visit me to
wdr.de again the  to
give the correct answer that after a little i always have
fun taking my language and it goes
better okay thats enough i wish you
a lot of fun learning the language and thank you thank you very much for your
attention